This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships.|||这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能以及复原力的标志。让自己经历一些艰难困苦。
And you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
And you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.|||然后你会走出困境，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字 2 百分比，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和而言是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每集节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.|||嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听和学习 Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your|||但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客
podcasts. And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. This week, we're going to talk about emotional unavailability across a number of settings, not just in romantic relationships, which I think is where our mind often goes, but also in our friendships and the emotional availability that we have within ourselves. I think this term, this concept has become a massive part of our shared dialogue recently. I see it being talked about
podcasts. And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. This week, we're going to talk about emotional unavailability across a number of settings, not just in romantic relationships, which I think is where our mind often goes, but also in our friendships and the emotional availability that we have within ourselves. I think this term, this concept has become a massive part of our shared dialogue recently. I see it being talked about|||播客。欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎新老听众回到本播客，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目。本周，我们将探讨多种环境下的情感不可得性，不仅是在我认为我们的大脑经常想到的浪漫关系中，还包括我们的友谊以及我们内心的情感可得性。我认为这个词、这个概念最近已经成为我们共同对话的巨大一部分。我看到它被谈论
everywhere and used to describe certain people and relationships. It's very much a psycho-babel term. And I think for good reason, it's a really important idea to discuss. But I also think there are a lot of misconceptions around this idea of emotional unavailability that I think we should clear up today. So I really want to break down exactly what it means to be emotionally unavailable versus available on today's episode. I think on a similar level, it's also vital to discuss in our 20s because it's really a critical element of the work that we need to do to become good humans, to have healthy, long-term relationships to be happy and emotional availability is so nuanced as is kind of the
everywhere and used to describe certain people and relationships. It's very much a psycho-babel term. And I think for good reason, it's a really important idea to discuss. But I also think there are a lot of misconceptions around this idea of emotional unavailability that I think we should clear up today. So I really want to break down exactly what it means to be emotionally unavailable versus available on today's episode. I think on a similar level, it's also vital to discuss in our 20s because it's really a critical element of the work that we need to do to become good humans, to have healthy, long-term relationships to be happy and emotional availability is so nuanced as is kind of the|||无处不在，并用来描述某些人和关系。这很大程度上是一个心理学行话术语。我认为有充分的理由，这是一个非常重要的讨论理念。但我也认为围绕情感不可得性这个概念存在很多误解，我认为我们今天应该澄清这些误解。所以我真的很想在今天的节目中详细剖析情感不可得性与情感可得性的真正含义。我认为在同样的层面，在我们的20多岁讨论这一点也至关重要，因为这确实是我们成为好人、拥有健康的长期关系、获得幸福所需要做的工作的关键要素，而且情感可得性非常微妙，就像
psychology behind it really. I think we do often think about it in terms of our relationships, but as we always say on this show, the most important relationship you will ever have is the one that you have with yourself. And something that I think isn't discussed about enough is that you're never really going to be able to be emotionally available to others or vulnerable or find a partner who is emotionally available if you're not in touch with your own emotional needs. So I really want to focus on that today. But I think on that same level, a massive element of our 20s is romantic relationships. I get questions about emotional unavailability and romantic relationships all the time and let me tell you I have dated and met enough emotionally unavailable people to write a book
psychology behind it really. I think we do often think about it in terms of our relationships, but as we always say on this show, the most important relationship you will ever have is the one that you have with yourself. And something that I think isn't discussed about enough is that you're never really going to be able to be emotionally available to others or vulnerable or find a partner who is emotionally available if you're not in touch with your own emotional needs. So I really want to focus on that today. But I think on that same level, a massive element of our 20s is romantic relationships. I get questions about emotional unavailability and romantic relationships all the time and let me tell you I have dated and met enough emotionally unavailable people to write a book|||背后的心理学一样。我想我们确实经常从我们的关系来考虑它，但正如我们在这个节目中所说的那样，你拥有的最重要的关系是你与自己的关系。我认为有一件事讨论得还不够，那就是如果你没有与自己的情感需求保持联系，你将永远无法真正对他人情感开放、脆弱，或者找到一个情感开放的伴侣。所以我今天真的很想专注于这一点。但我认为在同样的层面上，我们20多岁的一个巨大要素是浪漫关系。我一直收到关于情感不可得性和浪漫关系的问题，坦白说，我约会和遇到过的情感不可得的人已经多到可以写一本书了
of this batter and I think these days it seems a lot harder to truly know someone and be vulnerable because a lot of people are more transactional about their relationships and this often stems from emotional unavailability and I think it could be really terrible to want to connect with someone and really care about them but find that they're really closed off they're unable to express their feelings or they're tied down by emotions from a previous relationship. So how do we identify these people? And what do we do in the face of emotional unavailability? I think our tendency is to keep pushing these individuals and thinking that they will change or that we can change them. But what will become apparent, I think, as we dive into the psychology, is that that's not always the case.
of this batter and I think these days it seems a lot harder to truly know someone and be vulnerable because a lot of people are more transactional about their relationships and this often stems from emotional unavailability and I think it could be really terrible to want to connect with someone and really care about them but find that they're really closed off they're unable to express their feelings or they're tied down by emotions from a previous relationship. So how do we identify these people? And what do we do in the face of emotional unavailability? I think our tendency is to keep pushing these individuals and thinking that they will change or that we can change them. But what will become apparent, I think, as we dive into the psychology, is that that's not always the case.|||我深有体会，而且我认为现在要真正了解一个人并向其敞开心扉似乎难得多，因为许多人在处理关系时更具功利性，这通常源于情感不可得性。我认为，如果你想与某人建立连接并真正关心他们，却发现他们非常封闭、无法表达自己的感受，或者被上一段关系的情绪所束缚，这种感觉可能会非常糟糕。那么我们如何识别这些人呢？面对情感不可得性，我们该怎么办？我认为我们的倾向是不断推动这些个体，认为他们会改变或者我们可以改变他们。但随着我们深入探讨心理学，我认为显而易见的是，情况并非总是如此。
and I certainly don't think it's the way that we should do things. And I think the real hard truth of the matter is that our own emotional unavailability is what actually attracts these people. So let's talk about it today. Let's talk about all those nuances. We're going to break down exactly what emotional availability versus unavailability looks like, how it manifests in our relationships, what it means on a personal and individual level, how to kind of cultivate emotional. availability within yourself. And I also want to talk on, you know, some of the origins and the
and I certainly don't think it's the way that we should do things. And I think the real hard truth of the matter is that our own emotional unavailability is what actually attracts these people. So let's talk about it today. Let's talk about all those nuances. We're going to break down exactly what emotional availability versus unavailability looks like, how it manifests in our relationships, what it means on a personal and individual level, how to kind of cultivate emotional. availability within yourself. And I also want to talk on, you know, some of the origins and the|||我当然认为这不是我们做事的方式。我认为这件事真正残酷的真相是，正是我们自己内在的情感不可得性吸引了这些人。所以我们今天来谈谈这个。我们来谈谈所有这些微妙之处。我们将详细剖析情感可得性与不可得性的具体表现，它们如何在我们的关系中体现，它在个人和个体层面上意味着什么，以及如何在自己内心培养情感可得性。我还想谈谈，你知道的，一些起源和
difference between men and women when it comes to this concept and how we can really begin to recognize emotional unavailability in ourselves and in others. So there is a lot to cover, so much to cover, but I'm also really excited for this episode. I think it really is essential listening for anyone in this decade. So let's get into it. As we always do, let's firstly break down the basics. What exactly is emotional unavailability and where did the concept originate? I think it's important to look at emotional availability as a starting point because the profile of what an emotionally available person looks like kind of allows us to understand emotional unavailability a lot better. If you are someone who is emotionally available,
difference between men and women when it comes to this concept and how we can really begin to recognize emotional unavailability in ourselves and in others. So there is a lot to cover, so much to cover, but I'm also really excited for this episode. I think it really is essential listening for anyone in this decade. So let's get into it. As we always do, let's firstly break down the basics. What exactly is emotional unavailability and where did the concept originate? I think it's important to look at emotional availability as a starting point because the profile of what an emotionally available person looks like kind of allows us to understand emotional unavailability a lot better. If you are someone who is emotionally available,|||男女在这个概念上的区别，以及我们如何才能真正开始认识到自己和他人身上的情感不可得性。所以有太多内容要涵盖了，但我也对这一集感到非常兴奋。我认为这对于处于这个十年的任何人来说绝对是必听之作。那么让我们切入正题吧。像往常一样，让我们首先剖析基础知识。究竟什么是情感不可得性，这个概念起源于哪里？我认为把情感可得性作为起点很重要，因为一个情感可得的人的画像在某种程度上能让我们更好地理解情感不可得性。如果你是一个情感可得的人，
I hope that is all of us who are listening, that essentially means that you are able to to express your emotions in a healthy manner. You can form meaningful connections with others. You display commitment, particularly in romantic relationships. You're not afraid to be vulnerable. You are consistent in your emotional approach. You have meaningful conversations. And you're able to be honest about how you're feeling. Even if someone doesn't exhibit all of these traits, it doesn't mean that you're necessarily unavailable. You know, there are a range of factors as to why we're not vulnerable with everyone or why you haven't been in a committed relationship. Sometimes it is personal preference or you just haven't found the right person.
I hope that is all of us who are listening, that essentially means that you are able to to express your emotions in a healthy manner. You can form meaningful connections with others. You display commitment, particularly in romantic relationships. You're not afraid to be vulnerable. You are consistent in your emotional approach. You have meaningful conversations. And you're able to be honest about how you're feeling. Even if someone doesn't exhibit all of these traits, it doesn't mean that you're necessarily unavailable. You know, there are a range of factors as to why we're not vulnerable with everyone or why you haven't been in a committed relationship. Sometimes it is personal preference or you just haven't found the right person.|||我希望所有正在收听的我们都是这样，这基本上意味着你能够以健康的方式表达自己的情感。你可以与他人建立有意义的连接。你表现出承诺，尤其是在浪漫关系中。你不害怕暴露脆弱。你在情感处理方式上是连贯的。你有意义深长的对话。并且你能够诚实地表达自己的感受。即使某人没有表现出所有这些特质，也不意味着你一定就是不可得的。你知道，为什么我们不对所有人敞开心扉，或者为什么你没有进入一段坚定的关系，这背后有一系列因素。有时这是个人偏好，或者你只是还没找到对的人。
I think a big misconception attached to emotional unavailability is that every individual who is like this is afraid of commitment. That is true, I would say in some cases, maybe most, but it's not always the case. Many people who we would classify as emotionally unavailable do find themselves in in long-term partnerships and marriages. They want love like every other living and breathing person on this planet, but it's what occurs in those relationships that is the true hallmark of emotional unavailability. An emotionally unavailable person is going to have a hard time giving and receiving and reciprocating emotions
I think a big misconception attached to emotional unavailability is that every individual who is like this is afraid of commitment. That is true, I would say in some cases, maybe most, but it's not always the case. Many people who we would classify as emotionally unavailable do find themselves in in long-term partnerships and marriages. They want love like every other living and breathing person on this planet, but it's what occurs in those relationships that is the true hallmark of emotional unavailability. An emotionally unavailable person is going to have a hard time giving and receiving and reciprocating emotions|||我认为与情感不可得性相关的一个巨大误解是，所有这样的人都害怕承诺。这确实是真的，我想在某些情况下，也许大多数情况下是这样，但并非总是如此。许多我们归类为情感不可得的人确实发现自己身处长期伴侣关系和婚姻中。他们和这个星球上的其他每一个活生生的人一样渴望爱，但在这些关系中发生的事情才是情感不可得性的真正标志。一个情感不可得的人将很难付出、接受和回报情感
or being vulnerable and open with those in their lives. and it is normally the case that these people are highly socially advanced and they will seek out romantic encounters but when it comes to the complex emotional situations that are bound to occur in any long-term relationship when it comes to conflict or being emotionally intimate and committed they become really anxious they can't cope they shut down or they flee altogether so what happens is that these individuals may find themselves married or in long-term relationships or with lots of friends, but they're going to be lacking because they are unable to reach the depths of their emotions and share what they're really feeling in a manner that is
or being vulnerable and open with those in their lives. and it is normally the case that these people are highly socially advanced and they will seek out romantic encounters but when it comes to the complex emotional situations that are bound to occur in any long-term relationship when it comes to conflict or being emotionally intimate and committed they become really anxious they can't cope they shut down or they flee altogether so what happens is that these individuals may find themselves married or in long-term relationships or with lots of friends, but they're going to be lacking because they are unable to reach the depths of their emotions and share what they're really feeling in a manner that is|||或者对生活中的人保持脆弱和开放。通常情况下，这些人社交能力极强，他们会寻找浪漫邂逅，但当涉及到任何长期关系中不可避免的复杂情感状况，当涉及到冲突或情感亲密与承诺时，他们会变得非常焦虑、无法应对、自我封闭甚至彻底逃避。所以发生的情况是，这些人可能会发现自己已婚、处于长期关系中或者有很多朋友，但他们会有所欠缺，因为他们无法触及自己情感的最深处，并以某种方式分享他们真正的感受
conducive to real emotional closeness and intimacy. Of course, emotional unavailability looks very different in the context of dating, particularly in our 20s. As you can imagine, if you are someone who is not comfortable with your own emotions and lacks the ability to be emotionally intimate, you are going to have a very hard time dating, especially if you're looking for commitment. These individuals, if you've come across them, they may come off as really standoffish. They lack affection. They fail to communicate. They ghost you. They may like to call all the shots or they shut things down when it starts to get serious and vulnerable. And it's not because they don't necessarily want to go deeper, it's actually because they can't. All of these characteristics
conducive to real emotional closeness and intimacy. Of course, emotional unavailability looks very different in the context of dating, particularly in our 20s. As you can imagine, if you are someone who is not comfortable with your own emotions and lacks the ability to be emotionally intimate, you are going to have a very hard time dating, especially if you're looking for commitment. These individuals, if you've come across them, they may come off as really standoffish. They lack affection. They fail to communicate. They ghost you. They may like to call all the shots or they shut things down when it starts to get serious and vulnerable. And it's not because they don't necessarily want to go deeper, it's actually because they can't. All of these characteristics|||这有利于实现真正的精神贴近和亲密。当然，在约会的背景下，特别是在我们的20多岁时，情感不可得性的表现大不相同。正如你可以想象的那样，如果你是一个对自己的情感感到不自在且缺乏情感亲密能力的人，你在约会时会非常艰难，特别是如果你在寻找承诺的话。这些个体，如果你遇到过他们，他们可能会显得非常冷漠。他们缺乏爱意。他们无法沟通。他们会玩失踪（ghosting）。他们可能喜欢掌控一切，或者当事情开始变得严肃和脆弱时，他们就会把一切都关闭。这并不是因为他们不想深入了解，实际上是因为他们不能。所有这些特征
come from a place of fear, fear of rejection, fear of abandonment, fear of getting to know someone and then losing them. That is what's at the core, and it's a really crucial part of emotional unavailability. All of these evasive behavioral patterns, it's not because the person is a sociopath, it's because they're actually scared. Emotional unavailability, pulling away from others when things get tough, it's essentially a coping mechanism that has been unconsciously enlisted to protect someone from emotional pain. Most of the time, I think most individuals who are going through this or who have this kind of characteristic, they may not even consciously realize what they're doing, but more importantly, they don't understand the why. And to understand the why, we need to understand the
come from a place of fear, fear of rejection, fear of abandonment, fear of getting to know someone and then losing them. That is what's at the core, and it's a really crucial part of emotional unavailability. All of these evasive behavioral patterns, it's not because the person is a sociopath, it's because they're actually scared. Emotional unavailability, pulling away from others when things get tough, it's essentially a coping mechanism that has been unconsciously enlisted to protect someone from emotional pain. Most of the time, I think most individuals who are going through this or who have this kind of characteristic, they may not even consciously realize what they're doing, but more importantly, they don't understand the why. And to understand the why, we need to understand the|||都源于恐惧，害怕拒绝，害怕被抛弃，害怕去了解某人然后失去他们。这就是核心所在，也是情感不可得性中非常关键的一部分。所有这些逃避的行为模式，并不是因为这个人是反社会者，而是因为他们真的很害怕。情感不可得性，在事情变得艰难时从他人身边退缩，本质上是一种无意识启用的应对机制，旨在保护某人免受情感痛苦。大多数时候，我认为经历这种情况或拥有这种特征的大多数人，甚至可能没有有意识地意识到自己在做什么，但更重要的是，他们并不理解为什么。要理解为什么，我们需要理解
of this concept, we need to understand the origins of this condition. You may have already put this together, but there is a lot of overlap between emotional unavailability and an avoidant attachment style, much like how people with an avoid an attachment style avoid emotional closeness, they withdraw, they suppress emotions, they're highly independent, they fear rejection, emotionally unavailable people are very much the same. They're highly similar and most of the time they're linked there was this one study conducted i think at uc berkeley and it looked at parent and child separation and reunion so this is what they use to understand attachment styles they essentially have a child in a room they ask their parent to leave for a few minutes and they observe
of this concept, we need to understand the origins of this condition. You may have already put this together, but there is a lot of overlap between emotional unavailability and an avoidant attachment style, much like how people with an avoid an attachment style avoid emotional closeness, they withdraw, they suppress emotions, they're highly independent, they fear rejection, emotionally unavailable people are very much the same. They're highly similar and most of the time they're linked there was this one study conducted i think at uc berkeley and it looked at parent and child separation and reunion so this is what they use to understand attachment styles they essentially have a child in a room they ask their parent to leave for a few minutes and they observe|||这个概念，我们需要理解这种状况的起源。你可能已经把这些联系在一起了，但情感不可得性与回避型依恋风格之间有很多重叠，就像拥有回避型依恋风格的人会避免情感亲密、退缩、压抑情绪、高度独立、害怕拒绝一样，情感不可得的人也是如此。他们高度相似，而且大多数时候它们是相连的。我记得加州大学伯克利分校曾进行过这样一项研究，它观察了父母与孩子的离别和重聚，这就是他们用来理解依恋风格的方法，他们基本上让一个孩子待在一个房间里，要求他们的父母离开几分钟并观察
how the child reacts when they return and based on their reaction based on their behavior these psychologists or the person observing can understand their attachment style. They ran one of these studies and what they found was that emotional unavailability was linked to avoidant attachment style or attachment disorganization. And we know that our attachment styles begin in infancy and in childhood and many psychologists theorize that this is where the origins of emotional unavailability lie as well. When they had a bit of a deeper look into this idea, researchers found that most people who meet this profile have had an upbringing that is characterized by a lack of emotional closeness with their caregiver. Or they report having a parent who was unresponsive to their emotional needs,
how the child reacts when they return and based on their reaction based on their behavior these psychologists or the person observing can understand their attachment style. They ran one of these studies and what they found was that emotional unavailability was linked to avoidant attachment style or attachment disorganization. And we know that our attachment styles begin in infancy and in childhood and many psychologists theorize that this is where the origins of emotional unavailability lie as well. When they had a bit of a deeper look into this idea, researchers found that most people who meet this profile have had an upbringing that is characterized by a lack of emotional closeness with their caregiver. Or they report having a parent who was unresponsive to their emotional needs,|||孩子回来时的反应，根据他们的反应和行为，这些心理学家或观察者可以了解他们的依恋风格。他们进行了其中一项研究，发现情感不可得性与回避型依恋风格或依恋混乱有关。我们知道我们的依恋风格始于婴儿期和童年期，许多心理学家推论，这也是情感不可得性起源的地方。当他们对这个想法进行更深入的研究时，研究人员发现，大多数符合这一特征的人都有这样的成长经历：缺乏与照顾者的情感亲密感。或者他们报告说，他们的父母对他们的情感需求没有回应，
didn't want to discuss hard things, was closed off, or didn't really have a great sense of empathy for their feelings. This is incredibly impactful on a child, especially during those formative years of life, because as we know, we learn how to function and perform in relationships based off of our parents. We use them as a blueprint. We mimic their behavior. So if your parent never showed you love, you probably never learned how to show it from others or how to receive that yourself. Emotional unavailability, it also stems from a deep. fear of intimacy and a fear of rejection. If you have been repeatedly rejected by a caregiver when you attempted to receive emotional support or comfort, you're going to learn through repeated
didn't want to discuss hard things, was closed off, or didn't really have a great sense of empathy for their feelings. This is incredibly impactful on a child, especially during those formative years of life, because as we know, we learn how to function and perform in relationships based off of our parents. We use them as a blueprint. We mimic their behavior. So if your parent never showed you love, you probably never learned how to show it from others or how to receive that yourself. Emotional unavailability, it also stems from a deep. fear of intimacy and a fear of rejection. If you have been repeatedly rejected by a caregiver when you attempted to receive emotional support or comfort, you'll learn through repeated|||不想讨论困难的事情，思想封闭，或者对他们的感受没有太强的同理心。这对孩子的影响是极其深远的，尤其是在人生的那些成型期，因为正如我们所知，我们是根据父母来学习如何在关系中运作和表现的。我们以他们为蓝图。我们模仿他们的行为。所以如果你的父母从未向你展示过爱，你可能永远不会学会如何向他人展示爱，或者如何自己接受爱。情感不可得性，也源于对亲密关系的深深恐惧和对拒绝的恐惧。如果你在试图获得情感支持或安慰时屡次遭到照顾者的拒绝，你会通过重复的
conditioning that you should suppress those feelings because it will cause pain if you don't. You will be rejected and it will hurt. So you shut off as a coping mechanism and that pattern of repeated behavior, that learned mechanism, because becomes harder to change the older we get and the more it becomes ingrained. But maybe this individual, maybe you're thinking of someone, they have tried to break down those barriers, they've entered their 20s, they are trying to become closer with others and fight this instinct. They're dating. They're falling in love. All seems to be going really well. But we all know that love doesn't come without its challenges. We've all had our hearts broken. We've been rejected a few times
conditioning that you should suppress those feelings because it will cause pain if you don't. You will be rejected and it will hurt. So you shut off as a coping mechanism and that pattern of repeated behavior, that learned mechanism, because becomes harder to change the older we get and the more it becomes ingrained. But maybe this individual, maybe you're thinking of someone, they have tried to break down those barriers, they've entered their 20s, they are trying to become closer with others and fight this instinct. They're dating. They're falling in love. All seems to be going really well. But we all know that love doesn't come without its challenges. We've all had our hearts broken. We've been rejected a few times|||条件反射认识到，你应该压抑这些感受，因为如果不这么做就会带来痛苦。你会遭到拒绝并且这会受伤。所以你作为一种应对机制而自我封闭，这种重复行为的模式、这种习得的机制，随着我们年龄的增长和它变得根深蒂固，会变得越来越难改变。但也许这个人，也许你正在想着某人，他们试图打破这些障碍，他们进入了20多岁，他们正试图与他人更亲近并对抗这种本能。他们在约会。他们在恋爱。一切似乎都进展顺利。但我们都知道爱并非没有挑战。我们都曾心碎过。我们都被拒绝过几次
and for most of us who are emotionally available or securely attached, we just kind of see this as part of the game, right? It's just part of life and we move on and we know that we'll find someone better. But the emotionally unavailable person doesn't see it that way. Those experiences just reinforce their initial belief that to avoid pain, they need to shut down. So those initial romantic encounters and learning experiences may actually have the effect of just reinforcing this pre-existing behavioral pattern. It's not all about childhood experiences though, something like a traumatic breakup, even the death of a former partner, a close friend, or the end of a relationship maybe because of cheating or abuse or a toxic catalyst,
and for most of us who are emotionally available or securely attached, we just kind of see this as part of the game, right? It's just part of life and we move on and we know that we'll find someone better. But the emotionally unavailable person doesn't see it that way. Those experiences just reinforce their initial belief that to avoid pain, they need to shut down. So those initial romantic encounters and learning experiences may actually have the effect of just reinforcing this pre-existing behavioral pattern. It's not all about childhood experiences though, something like a traumatic breakup, even the death of a former partner, a close friend, or the end of a relationship maybe because of cheating or abuse or a toxic catalyst,|||对于我们大多数情感可得或安全依恋的人来说，我们只是把这看作游戏的一部分，对吧？这只是生活的一部分，我们继续前行，我们知道我们会找到更好的人。但情感不可得的人并不这么看。这些经历只会巩固他们最初的信念，即为了避免痛苦，他们需要关闭自己。因此，那些最初的浪漫遭遇和学习经验可能实际上只会起到巩固这种预先存在的行为模式的作用。不过，这并不完全关乎童年经历，比如痛苦的分手，甚至是前伴侣、密友的去世，或者一段关系的结束可能是因为出轨、虐待或有毒的催化剂，
it can also trigger temporary or permanent emotional unavailability. Some experiences are so influential that they entirely change our attitudes towards intimacy and vulnerability. If you have been completely devastated by the end of a relationship, no matter what the context, our brains can often make a rapid but highly, a logical assumption that in order to avoid that pain in the future, we should avoid all further instances of commitment and vulnerability as a protective mechanism. At the end of the day,
it can also trigger temporary or permanent emotional unavailability. Some experiences are so influential that they entirely change our attitudes towards intimacy and vulnerability. If you have been completely devastated by the end of a relationship, no matter what the context, our brains can often make a rapid but highly, a logical assumption that in order to avoid that pain in the future, we should avoid all further instances of commitment and vulnerability as a protective mechanism. At the end of the day,|||它也可能引发暂时或永久的情感不可得性。有些经历极具影响力，以至于它们彻底改变了我们对亲密关系和脆弱性的态度。如果你曾被一段关系的结束彻底击垮，无论背景如何，我们的大脑通常会做出一个快速但高度逻辑化的假设：为了将来避免这种痛苦，我们应该作为一种保护机制，避免所有进一步的承诺和脆弱实例。归根结底，
the only thing our mind wants to do is help us to avoid pain and help us to survive, and intense emotions associated with the end of a relationship are painful. So unconsciously, the mind associates relationship with pain, commitment with pain, and it causes us to shut down and push away further instances of emotional intimacy. That is one of the big reasons why we always say, not to date anyone right out of a relationship. Chances are that their emotional capacity is at an all-time low and their emotional ability to commit is going to be highly stunted by their recent experience. This is particularly the case for men. I might get criticism for saying this, but honestly, the science does back it up. Men are much more likely to display emotional unavailability compared to
the only thing our mind wants to do is help us to avoid pain and help us to survive, and intense emotions associated with the end of a relationship are painful. So unconsciously, the mind associates relationship with pain, commitment with pain, and it causes us to shut down and push away further instances of emotional intimacy. That is one of the big reasons why we always say, not to date anyone right out of a relationship. Chances are that their emotional capacity is at an all-time low and their emotional ability to commit is going to be highly stunted by their recent experience. This is particularly the case for men. I might get criticism for saying this, but honestly, the science does back it up. Men are much more likely to display emotional unavailability compared to|||我们大脑想要做的唯一事情就是帮助我们避免痛苦并帮助我们生存，而与关系结束相关的强烈情感是痛苦的。因此，在无意识中，大脑将关系与痛苦联系起来，将承诺与痛苦联系起来，这导致我们自我封闭并推开进一步的情感亲密实例。这就是为什么我们总是说不要在刚结束一段感情后马上和任何人约会的一个重要原因。很有可能他们的情感容量处于历史最低点，并且他们承诺的情感能力将受到他们最近经历的极大阻碍。对于男性来说尤其如此。我说这话可能会遭到批评，但老实说，科学确实支持这一点。与女性相比，男性更有可能表现出情感不可得性
women, particularly in their 20s. And there are a few reasons why this is the case. We know that men's brains develop later than women. Women reach full synaptic and global maturity at 23 on average, compared to men at 26. So that's a three-year head start that women have. And the last part of our brain to fully mature is the frontal lobe. And that part of the brain is responsible for things like complex executive emotions, understanding and reacting to others' feelings, judgment, and our attitudes and personality. Our emotional availability and capacity to connect with others is directly correlated to the development of that lope and therefore it's going to show up a lot later in men than women which is why I think I get so many messages from women in their early 20s
women, particularly in their 20s. And there are a few reasons why this is the case. We know that men's brains develop later than women. Women reach full synaptic and global maturity at 23 on average, compared to men at 26. So that's a three-year head start that women have. And the last part of our brain to fully mature is the frontal lobe. And that part of the brain is responsible for things like complex executive emotions, understanding and reacting to others' feelings, judgment, and our attitudes and personality. Our emotional availability and capacity to connect with others is directly correlated to the development of that lope and therefore it's going to show up a lot later in men than women which is why I think I get so many messages from women in their early 20s|||尤其是20多岁的女性。造成这种情况有几个原因。我们知道男性的发育比女性晚。女性平均在23岁时达到突触和整体成熟，而男性则在26岁。所以女性有三年的领先优势。我们大脑最后完全成熟的部分是额叶。大脑的这一部分负责诸如复杂的执行情绪、理解和反应他人的感受、判断力以及我们的态度和个性等事情。我们的情感可得性和与他人建立连接的能力与该脑叶的发展直接相关，因此它在男性身上出现的时间会比女性晚得多，这就是为什么我认为我收到那么多来自20多岁出头女性的信息
really struggling with dating men who are so closed off and they're almost emotionally incapable and unwilling to commit it's not always the case but I do think it's rather frequent and there was this additional theory put forward by this psychologist. I don't know how to pronounce her name. Dr. Jernigan. If she's listening to this, she probably isn't. She can correct me, but let's go with Dr. Jernigan. And she suggested that men receive a lot more culturally reinforced messages from society
really struggling with dating men who are so closed off and they're almost emotionally incapable and unwilling to commit it's not always the case but I do think it's rather frequent and there was this additional theory put forward by this psychologist. I don't how to pronounce her name. Dr. Jernigan. If she's listening to this, she probably isn't. She can correct me, but let's go with Dr. Jernigan. And she suggested that men receive a lot more culturally reinforced messages from society|||她们在与那些非常封闭、几乎没有情感能力且不愿意承诺的男性约会时真的感到挣扎，虽然并非总是如此，但我确实认为这相当频繁。还有这位心理学家提出的额外理论。我不知道怎么发音她的名字。杰尼根博士。如果她在听这个——她可能没在听——她可以纠正我，但我们就叫她杰尼根博士吧。她提出，男性从社会中接受了更多文化强化的信息
that emotional vulnerability is weak. And in response, they develop patterns of emotional unavailability in an attempt to live up to their cultural and gender expectations. I do think that really aligns with my own personal experience, if I'm being honest. I've encountered a lot more men than women who I would say display signs of emotional unavailability. I've even dated a few of them, and it all follows very much the same pattern of experiences. They love the beginning of the relationship when it's all fun, and talking and sex and dates, but as soon as it becomes more committed and you have a fight
that emotional vulnerability is weak. And in response, they develop patterns of emotional unavailability in an attempt to live up to their cultural and gender expectations. I do think that really aligns with my own personal experience, if I'm being honest. I've encountered a lot more men than women who I would say display signs of emotional unavailability. I've even dated a few of them, and it all follows very much the same pattern of experiences. They love the beginning of the relationship when it's all fun, and talking and sex and dates, but as soon as it becomes more committed and you have a fight|||即情感上的脆弱是软弱的。作为回应，他们发展出了情感不可得性的模式，试图不辜负他们的文化和性别期望。老实说，我确实认为这非常符合我个人的经历。我遇到的表现出情感不可得性迹象的男性比女性要多得多。我甚至和其中的几个约会过，所有的经历都遵循着非常相似的模式。他们喜欢关系的开始，那时全是乐趣、谈话、性和约会，但一旦关系变得更加坚定，你们吵了一架
or you have to overcome some kind of disagreement, their knee-jerk reaction is to shut down and is to run. And we can understand the reasons why and the origins behind emotional unavailability, we could talk about it all day. But the truth is that it really sucks. It really sucks. It's really terrible to find someone that you connect with and whose company you enjoy, only to really discover that three or four months in, they are incapable of truly connecting with you or they push you away. And the thing is that they probably won't give you a reason either. Ghosting is actually a massive sign of emotional unavailability because these individuals don't have the capacity to navigate emotionally complex situations, such as ending it with someone.
or you have to overcome some kind of disagreement, their knee-jerk reaction is to shut down and is to run. And we can understand the reasons why and the origins behind emotional unavailability, we could talk about it all day. But the truth is that it really sucks. It really sucks. It's really terrible to find someone that you connect with and whose company you enjoy, only to really discover that three or four months in, they are incapable of truly connecting with you or they push you away. And the thing is that they probably won't give you a reason either. Ghosting is actually a massive sign of emotional unavailability because these individuals don't have the capacity to navigate emotionally complex situations, such as ending it with someone.|||或者你们必须克服某种分歧时，他们的本能反应就是自我封闭并逃跑。我们可以理解情感不可得性背后的原因和起源，我们可以一整天都在讨论这个。但事实是这真的很糟糕。真的太糟糕了。找到一个与你心灵相通且你喜欢其陪伴的人，却在交往三四个月后真正发现他们无法与你真正连接，或者他们把你推开，这真的很糟糕。关键是他们可能也不会给你一个理由。失踪实际上是情感不可得性的一个巨大标志，因为这些个体没有能力应对情感复杂的局面，比如和某人分手。
It is honestly so much more disappointing to me to receive a message from someone when things are ending or fizzling because I'm like, damn, that guy was actually emotionally available. I know that because when I'm being ghosted, it's a pretty clear sign that this person was never going to commit and they weren't going to go much deeper anyways because they cannot navigate complex emotional situations such as hurting someone's feelings or. or dealing out rejection or breaking up with someone. Regardless, we do want to avoid relationships or falling for people who display this repeated pattern of behavior. And let me say very clearly, if you think that you can fix someone, the chances are that that will get you nowhere.
It is honestly so much more disappointing to me to receive a message from someone when things are ending or fizzling because I'm like, damn, that guy was actually emotionally available. I know that because when I'm being ghosted, it's a pretty clear sign that this person was never going to commit and they weren't going to go much deeper anyways because they cannot navigate complex emotional situations such as hurting someone's feelings or. or dealing out rejection or breaking up with someone. Regardless, we do want to avoid relationships or falling for people who display this repeated pattern of behavior. And let me say very clearly, if you think that you can fix someone, the chances are that that will get you nowhere.|||老实说，当事情正在结束或无疾而终时收到某人的信息对我都更令人失望，因为我会想：天哪，那家伙实际上是情感可得的。我知道这一点，因为当我被无故拉黑失踪时，这是一个非常明显的信号，表明这个人永远不会做出承诺，而且无论如何他们都不会深入交往，因为他们无法驾驭复杂的情感状况，例如伤害某人的感情，或者发出拒绝，或者与某人分手。无论如何，我们确实希望避免与表现出这种重复行为模式的人建立关系或坠入爱河。让我非常明确地说，如果你认为你可以修复某人，那么很有可能这会让你一无所获。
The roots of emotional unavailability run very deep into our childhood wounds and unconscious coping mechanisms. that is not work that you can do for someone else. You cannot go into their brain and fix their early childhood experiences. You cannot force them to do anything. They're going to have to reach that decision for themselves, as disappointing as it may sound. But there is something that we can do.
The roots of emotional unavailability run very deep into our childhood wounds and unconscious coping mechanisms. that is not work that you can do for someone else. You cannot go into their brain and fix their early childhood experiences. You cannot force them to do anything. They're going to have to reach that decision for themselves, as disappointing as it may sound. But there is something that we can do.|||情感不可得性的根源深深扎根于我们的童年创伤和无意识的应对机制中。那不是你可以为别人做的工作。你不能进入他们的大脑去修复他们早期的童年经历。你不能强迫他们做任何事情。尽管听起来可能令人失望，但他们必须自己做出这个决定。但有些事情是我们能做的。
Often, one of the reasons we find ourselves in a cycle of attracting or dating people who are emotionally unavailable is because we ourselves are not emotionally available. and we are using someone else's lack of emotional commitment as a very easy way to deflect or ignore our own unavailability. There have been studies on this. Emotionally unavailable people are often more attracted to each other because when you really think about it, they share the same desire. They share the same goal. And that is to avoid intimacy. And that is to avoid vulnerability. So they're more aligned on the value set, they're more aligned on their desires.
Often, one of the reasons we find ourselves in a cycle of attracting or dating people who are emotionally unavailable is because we ourselves are not emotionally available. and we are using someone else's lack of emotional commitment as a very easy way to deflect or ignore our own unavailability. There have been studies on this. Emotionally unavailable people are often more attracted to each other because when you really think about it, they share the same desire. They share the same goal. And that is to avoid intimacy. And that is to avoid vulnerability. So they're more aligned on the value set, they're more aligned on their desires.|||通常，我们发现自己陷入吸引或与情感不可得的人约会的循环中的原因之一，是因为我们自己本身就是情感不可得的。我们正在利用别人缺乏情感承诺，作为转移或忽视我们自身不可得性的非常简单的方式。对此有过相关研究。情感不可得的人往往更容易被彼此吸引，因为当你真正思考时，他们有着相同的欲望。他们有着相同的目标。那就是避免亲密。那就是避免脆弱。所以在价值观上他们更加一致，在欲望上他们也更加一致。
You may also find that you're actually not attracted to emotionally available people because it would put you in a situation in which you would have to be vulnerable. And you would have to reciprocate their candor and their depth. And sometimes emotional unavailability, the will they, won't they, is kind of exciting. And that's a big sign that you might be the unavailable one. if you are attracted to inconsistency and attracted to anxiety. Like I mentioned at the beginning, we do often think about emotional availability in terms of our relationships, but the most important relationship you will have is the one you have with yourself.
You may also find that you're actually not attracted to emotionally available people because it would put you in a situation in which you would have to be vulnerable. And you would have to reciprocate their candor and their depth. And sometimes emotional unavailability, the will they, won't they, is kind of exciting. And that's a big sign that you might be the unavailable one. if you are attracted to inconsistency and attracted to anxiety. Like I mentioned at the beginning, we do often think about emotional availability in terms of our relationships, but the most important relationship you will have is the one you have with yourself.|||你可能还会发现，你实际上并不被情感可得的人所吸引，因为那会把你置于一种你必须表现得脆弱的境地。你必须回报他们的坦诚和深度。有时情感不可得性，那种他们会还是不会的纠缠，有点令人兴奋。这是一个强烈的信号，表明你可能才是那个不可得的人。如果你被不一致性和焦虑所吸引。正如我一开始提到的，我们确实经常从我们的关系来考虑情感可得性，但你拥有的最重要的关系是你与自己的关系。
You will never be able to be emotionally available to others if you are not in touch with your own emotional needs. you will repeatedly attract the same types of people into your life over and over again if you don't address the underlying reason why this is. So we are going to talk about how you can cultivate your own emotional availability in just a second. Here is the big secret. If you want to attract people and grow your relationships with those who are emotionally available, you won't get anywhere if you don't work on yourself first. I think that there is a growing rate of emotional shallowness in this generation. Because of a lot of factors, many outside of our control,
You will never be able to be emotionally available to others if you are not in touch with your own emotional needs. you will repeatedly attract the same types of people into your life over and over again if you don't address the underlying reason why this is. So we are going to talk about how you can cultivate your own emotional availability in just a second. Here is the big secret. If you want to attract people and grow your relationships with those who are emotionally available, you won't get anywhere if you don't work on yourself first. I think that there is a growing rate of emotional shallowness in this generation. Because of a lot of factors, many outside of our control,|||如果你不了解自己的情感需求，你将永远无法对他人情感开放。如果你不解决这背后的根本原因，你会一次又一次地把同类型的人吸引到你的生活中。所以我们接下来马上要谈谈你如何培养自己的情感可得性。这里有一个巨大的秘密。如果你想吸引人并与那些情感可得的人发展关系，如果你不先自我完善，你将一事无成。我认为这一代人的情感肤浅化程度越来越高。由于许多因素，其中许多是我们无法控制的，
but it can be seen in this rise of entirely new terms that we have for relationships that we haven't really encountered in previous generations, terms like situationships. I actually, I had to explain this term to my mum the other day, and she was so confused that you could technically be in a relationship with someone, but not be committed. And she made an excellent point that it's likely because a lot of people in our generation are more afraid of being emotionally vulnerable because of societal shifts away from commitment
but it can be seen in this rise of entirely new terms that we have for relationships that we haven't really encountered in previous generations, terms like situationships. I actually, I had to explain this term to my mum the other day, and she was so confused that you could technically be in a relationship with someone, but not be committed. And she made an excellent point that it's likely because a lot of people in our generation are more afraid of being emotionally vulnerable because of societal shifts away from commitment|||但这一点可以从我们对关系的全新术语的兴起中看出，这些术语在以往的几代人中并未真正遇到过，比如“情境关系”（situationships）这样的词。实际上，前几天我不得不向我妈妈解释这个词，她非常困惑，怎么可能在技术上与某人建立关系，却没有承诺。她提出了一个极好的观点：这很可能是因为由于社会从承诺的转变，我们这一代的许多人更加害怕在情感上变得脆弱
and away from traditional relationship archetypes. Some of that is very empowering, I think, all power to people who want to decide how their relationships function, and they do so consensually, and they do so by communicating that, but I think it's also important to reflect on the impact that this may have on our emotional welfare and our ability to connect, particularly when dating. So what are some of the signs that you are the emotionally unavailable one? It doesn't necessarily mean that there's something wrong with you. I will just put that disclaimer out there.
and away from traditional relationship archetypes. Some of that is very empowering, I think, all power to people who want to decide how their relationships function, and they do so consensually, and they do so by communicating that, but I think it's also important to reflect on the impact that this may have on our emotional welfare and our ability to connect, particularly when dating. So what are some of the signs that you are the emotionally unavailable one? It doesn't necessarily mean that there's something wrong with you. I will just put that disclaimer out there.|||并且远离了传统的恋爱原型。我认为其中一些是非常赋予赋权的，全力支持那些想要决定其关系如何运作的人，他们以双方同意的方式这样做，并且通过沟通来做到这一点，但我认为同样重要的是反思这可能对我们的情感福祉和建立连接的能力产生的影响，特别是在约会时。那么，你是那个情感不可得的人的一些迹象是什么？这并不一定意味着你有什么毛病。我先在这里做个免责声明。
It's really just a pattern of behavior and a habit that is formed in response to things most of the time outside of our control. I don't think anyone wakes up and is like, I want to be emotionally unavailable. I want to push away the people that love me. It's not a conscious decision. It just kind of happens. But it's still worth being able to identify that. I think that's the first step to being able to heal that part of yourself.
It's really just a pattern of behavior and a habit that is formed in response to things most of the time outside of our control. I don't think anyone wakes up and is like, I want to be emotionally unavailable. I want to push away the people that love me. It's not a conscious decision. It just kind of happens. But it's still worth being able to identify that. I think that's the first step to being able to heal that part of yourself.|||这实际上只是一种行为模式和习惯，是为了应对大多数时候超出我们控制的事情而形成的。我不认为有人醒来后会说：我想成为一个情感不可得的人。我想推开那些爱我的人。这不是一个有意识的决定。它只是自然而然地发生了。但它仍然值得我们去识别。我认为这是治愈自己那部分自我的第一步。
The first big major sign is that you fear intimacy. Maybe you have come out of a really traumatic breakup, a really traumatic situation. and the idea of being in a long-term relationship leaves you feeling really anxious. Maybe you've been hurt before. And the concept of having to open up to someone in a long-term partnership, potentially losing them, maybe encountering hard emotions, that's really difficult for you to imagine. And it's almost a fear of response. You feel your gut churning.
The first big major sign is that you fear intimacy. Maybe you have come out of a really traumatic breakup, a really traumatic situation. and the idea of being in a long-term relationship leaves you feeling really anxious. Maybe you've been hurt before. And the concept of having to open up to someone in a long-term partnership, potentially losing them, maybe encountering hard emotions, that's really difficult for you to imagine. And it's almost a fear of response. You feel your gut churning.|||第一个重大迹象是你害怕亲密关系。也许你刚从一段非常痛苦的分手、一种非常痛苦的境地中走出来。长期处于一段关系中的想法让你感到非常焦虑。也许你以前受过伤。在长期的伴侣关系中不得不向某人敞开心扉、可能失去他们、可能会遇到艰难的情感，这个概念对你来说真的很难想象。这几乎是一种恐惧的反应。你感到内心翻江倒海。
You feel anxious. You feel nauseous. That's a fear of interest. intimacy. And this may result in the second indicator, which is that you avoid commitment. Obviously, like we stipulated, this isn't always the case, but sometimes you may like to keep your options open to prevent yourself from having to truly have to open up to one person. It's a fear mechanism. We use it to protect ourselves, but it's also a sign of emotional unavailability. This next one may be unexpected, but let me explain it a little bit more.
You feel anxious. You feel nauseous. That's a fear of interest. intimacy. And this may result in the second indicator, which is that you avoid commitment. Obviously, like we stipulated, this isn't always the case, but sometimes you may like to keep your options open to prevent yourself from having to truly have to open up to one person. It's a fear mechanism. We use it to protect ourselves, but it's also a sign of emotional unavailability. This next one may be unexpected, but let me explain it a little bit more.|||你感到焦虑。你感到恶心。那是对亲密关系的恐惧。这可能会导致第二个指标，即你逃避承诺。显然，正如我们所规定的，情况并非总是如此，但有时你可能喜欢保持开放的选择，以防止自己不得不真正向一个人敞开心扉。这是一种恐惧机制。我们用它来保护自己，但这也是情感不可得性的一个标志。接下来这个可能会出乎意料，但让我多解释一点。
you may find that you have a lot of superficial friends and very few meaningful relationships. You have built up this wide variety of acquaintances, of people that you can casually go for a drink with or talk to, but none of them know you very deeply. And there's a reason behind that. It's because there is less chance of being abandoned or rejected or feeling truly alone and vulnerable if you have quote unquote backups and people who you aren't truly emotionally close to. In that way, you avoid pain. I think it's an important reminder that emotional unavailability, it isn't just reserved for our romantic
you may find that you have a lot of superficial friends and very few meaningful relationships. You have built up this wide variety of acquaintances, of people that you can casually go for a drink with or talk to, but none of them know you very deeply. And there is a reason behind that. It's because there is less chance of being abandoned or rejected or feeling truly alone and vulnerable if you have quote unquote backups and people who you aren't truly emotionally close to. In that way, you avoid pain. I think it's an important reminder that emotional unavailability, it isn't just reserved for our romantic|||你可能会发现你有很多泛泛之交的朋友，却很少有意义深长的关系。你建立形形色色的熟人圈子，有那些你可以随意去喝一杯或交谈的人，但没有一个人对你了解得很深。这背后是有原因的。这是因为如果你拥有所谓的“备胎”和那些你并非真正情感亲密的人，被抛弃或拒绝或感到真正的孤独和脆弱的机会就会减少。通过这种方式，你避免了痛苦。我认为这是一个重要的提醒：情感不可得性并不只限于我们的浪漫关系。
relationships. Our brains don't shut down and switch on that part of our brain when it comes to friendships. And at the core of emotional unavailability is a fear of rejection and abandonment. And that can come from multiple directions and multiple types of relationships. I'm sure that there have been many of you out there who have had better and closer and deeper relationships with your friends than some of the people that you've dated. And when those friendships might not work when you have disagreements, that can sometimes hurt a lot more. So if you find yourself surveying your friends and recognizing that you have voluntary,
relationships. Our brains don't shut down and switch on that part of our brain when it comes to friendships. And at the core of emotional unavailability is a fear of rejection and abandonment. And that can come from multiple directions and multiple types of relationships. I'm sure that there have been many of you out there who have had better and closer and deeper relationships with your friends than some of the people that you'd dated. And when those friendships might not work when you have disagreements, that can sometimes hurt a lot more. So if you find yourself surveying your friends and recognizing that you have voluntary,|||关系。当谈到友谊时，我们的大脑并不会关闭并开启大脑的那一部分。情感不可得性的核心是对拒绝和被抛弃的恐惧。这可以来自多个方向和多种类型的关系。我确信你们当中有许多人与朋友的关系比你们约会过的一些人更好、更亲密、更深厚。而当这些友谊在你们产生分歧时可能无法维系时，那有时会带来更大的伤害。所以如果你发现自己审视自己的朋友，并认识到你是自愿的、
and deliberately chosen more shallow relationships and friendships compared to those which are deep and meaningful, it may be indicative of emotional unavailability. This final sign, I also think it's interesting, but I also think it's common sense. You may find that you're very conflict averse. You get defensive easily and you turn off during emotionally complex situations. If you are around people who want emotional support,
and deliberately chosen more shallow relationships and friendships compared to those which are deep and meaningful, it may be indicative of emotional unavailability. This final sign, I also think it's interesting, but I also think it's common sense. You may find that you're very conflict averse. You get defensive easily and you turn off during emotionally complex situations. If you are around people who want emotional support,|||刻意选择更肤浅的关系和友谊，而放弃那些深厚且有意义的关系，这可能表明存在情感不可得性。这最后一个迹象，我也觉得很有趣，但我也认为这是常识。你可能会发现你非常厌恶冲突。你很容易产生防备心理，并且在情感复杂的局势中会选择关闭自己。如果你身边的那些人想要情感支持，
you may automatically try and minimize their emotions by changing the subject or simply withdrawing. You might also want to keep topics light so that they stick to the surface level stuff, to the comfortable themes that you feel safe discussing. That's because you're afraid of opening up. If you may be listening to this and being like, that sounds like my friend, I will say it's not because they want to shut you down. It's not because they want to reject your needs or devalitate or minimize your reactions. It's because they feel trapped and they don't want to be forced into a position where they have to reciprocate or they have to share.
you may automatically try and minimize their emotions by changing the subject or simply withdrawing. You might also want to keep topics light so that they stick to the surface level stuff, to the comfortable themes that you feel safe discussing. That's because you're afraid of opening up. If you may be listening to this and being like, that sounds like my friend, I will say it's not because they want to shut you down. It's not because they want to reject your needs or devalitate or minimize your reactions. It's because they feel trapped and they don't want to be forced into a position where they have to reciprocate or they have to share.|||你可能会通过转移话题或直接退缩来自动试着淡化他们的情绪。你可能还希望保持话题轻松，以便它们停留在表面水平的事情上，停留在你觉得讨论起来安全的舒适主题上。那是因为你害怕敞开心扉。如果你在听这个时可能会觉得：这听起来像我的朋友，我要说的是，这并不是因为他们想压制你。这不是因为他们想拒绝你的需求，贬低或淡化你的反应。这是因为他们感到被困住了，他们不想被强迫进入一种必须回报或必须分享的境地。
The good news, though, is that emotional unavailability, it's just a description. It's not an indictment or a life sentence. like we've discussed many of the factors that influence emotional unavailability are beyond our control. But I also want to recognize that just because they are beyond our control doesn't mean that we don't have agency. And it can be really rough to have that self-awareness whereby you can identify that you are emotionally unavailable, but you don't really know what to do. But that's what we're here for today. So how do we realize our most emotionally available and overall?
The good news, though, is that emotional unavailability, it's just a description. It's not an indictment or a life sentence. like we've discussed many of the factors that influence emotional unavailability are beyond our control. But I also want to recognize that just because they are beyond our control doesn't mean that we don't have agency. And it can be really rough to have that self-awareness whereby you can identify that you are emotionally unavailable, but you don't really know what to do. But that's what we're here for today. So how do we realize our most emotionally available and overall?|||不过好消息是，情感不可得性只是一种描述。它不是起诉书或无期徒刑。正如我们所讨论的，许多影响情感不可得性的因素超出了我们的控制。但我也想认识到，仅仅因为它们超出了我们的控制，并不意味着我们没有自主权。拥有那种自我觉察可能会非常艰难，即你能识别出自己情感不可得，但你真的不知道该怎么办。但这正是我们今天来到这里的目的。那么我们如何实现我们最情感可得且整体上的？
authentic selves and how do we work towards choosing emotionally available partners? The key is to start internally. Often our inability to be emotionally open. It stems from a difficulty with being honest with ourselves about our emotional needs and our desires. We don't just avoid the complex feelings and experiences of others. We also tend to suppress our own hard emotions because they are difficult to manage if you can't share them or you can't trust others with your vulnerability. It's important to work on
authentic selves and how do we work towards choosing emotionally available partners? The key is to start internally. Often our inability to be emotionally open. It stems from a difficulty with being honest with ourselves about our emotional needs and our desires. We don't just avoid the complex feelings and experiences of others. We also tend to suppress our own hard emotions because they are difficult to manage if you can't share them or you can't trust others with your vulnerability. It's important to work on|||真实的自我，我们又该如何努力选择情感可得的伴侣呢？关键是要从内部开始。通常我们无法在情感上保持开放。它源于对自己情感需求和欲望的不诚实带来的困难。我们不仅逃避他人的复杂感受和经历。我们也倾向于压抑自己痛苦的情绪，因为如果你无法分享它们，或者无法信任他人并向其袒露你的脆弱，这些情绪就会很难管理。重要的是要致力于
identifying what you're feeling when you're feeling it. I think a lot of us, emotionally available or not, have a tendency to pick up our phones, scroll TikTok, switch on the television, distract ourselves when uncomfortable emotions kind of bubble to the surface. Do whatever you can to avoid that. That goes for everyone. It's uncomfortable, but sometimes you need to need to feel uncomfortable to grow. And being able to recognize your own feelings and manage them yourself is a massive pathway to being emotionally available with others. Sometimes this comes from childhood wounds. I would say that is the biggest predictor. And particularly the behaviors of our caregivers and our parents, the sad reality is, no matter how hard you try, you cannot go back to
identifying what you're feeling when you're feeling it. I think a lot of us, emotionally available or not, have a tendency to pick up our phones, scroll TikTok, switch on the television, distract ourselves when uncomfortable emotions kind of bubble to the surface. Do whatever you can to avoid that. That goes for everyone. It's uncomfortable, but sometimes you need to need to feel uncomfortable to grow. And being able to recognize your own feelings and manage them yourself is a massive pathway to being emotionally available with others. Sometimes this comes from childhood wounds. I would say that is the biggest predictor. And particularly the behaviors of our caregivers and our parents, the sad reality is, no matter how hard you try, you cannot go back to|||识别你在感受什么，以及你是什么时候感受到它的。我认为我们中的很多人，无论情感是否可得，当不舒服的情绪冒泡浮出水面时，往往倾向于拿起手机、刷TikTok、打开电视、分散注意力。尽一切可能避免这种情况。这对所有人都适用。这很不舒服，但有时你需要体验不舒服才能成长。能够识别自己的感受并自己管理它们，是与他人保持情感可得性的重要途径。有时这来自于童年创伤。我可以说这是最大的预测因素。尤其是我们的照顾者和父母的行为，可悲的现实是，无论你多么努力，你都无法回到
childhood and fix things. You cannot reshape how you think things should have gone. You can't undo the past, but what you can do is reparent yourself at the moment you are in now. I did a whole episode on healing your inner child. I think it's really valuable if this is something that's been on your mind for a while, but a brief synopsis of this episode is that in order to heal childhood attachment wounds that may be contributing to your emotional unavailability, you have a brief synopsis of have to start treating yourself as if you are speaking to your childhood self, as if the tiny version of you is sitting in front of you and you need to protect them. So you need to create a personal and internal environment for them to feel safe by letting yourself feel your emotions, showing
childhood and fix things. You cannot reshape how you think things should have gone. You can't undo the past, but what you can do is reparent yourself at the moment you are in now. I did a whole episode on healing your inner child. I think it's really valuable if this is something that's been on your mind for a while, but a brief synopsis of this episode is that in order to heal childhood attachment wounds that may be contributing to your emotional unavailability, you have a brief synopsis of have to start treating yourself as if you are speaking to your childhood self, as if the tiny version of you is sitting in front of you and you need to protect them. So you need to create a personal and internal environment for them to feel safe by letting yourself feel your emotions, showing|||童年去修复事情。你无法重塑你认为事情本来应该怎样发展。你无法抹去过去，但你能做的是在你现在的时刻重新养育自己。我做过一整集关于疗愈内在小孩的节目。如果这是你一直在心头盘旋的事情，我认为这真的很有价值，但这一集的简短总结是，为了疗愈可能导致你情感不可得的童年依恋创伤，你必须开始这样对待自己：就好像你在和童年时期的自己说话一样，就好像那个小小的你正坐在你面前，你需要保护他们。所以你需要通过让自己感受自己的情绪，展现出个人和内在的环境，让他们感到安全。
unconditional love for yourself, whatever that means for you, and creating emotional safety. This may involve going to therapy or engaging in some kind of emotional release like journaling, but it also involves just giving your inner child space to feel without shutting them down, without ignoring it, without suppressing it, because that mimics the way that you may have been shut down by a parent during childhood. And by connecting deeper with your emotions, you really do profoundly shift your ability to connect with others. And you'll begin to notice, I think, a shift in the quality and the depth,
无条件地爱自己（无论这对你意味着什么），并创造情感上的安全感。这可能包括去看心理医生，或者进行某种情感宣泄，比如写日记，但它也包括给你的内在小孩留出空间去感受，而不是压抑、忽视或粗暴地打断他们，因为这模仿了你在童年时期可能被父母压抑的方式。通过更深地与你的情感连接，你确实会深刻地改变与他人连接的能力。我想，你会开始注意到，关系的质量和深度发生了转变，
not just of your relationships or your relationships with your friends or your family, but in how you treat yourself as well. A wall will probably come down and it may be painful. There's a lot of suppressed stuff that builds up from childhood or from experiences of redoubt. or breakups or trauma, but I think a lot of hard things are worth doing, and this is one of them. All of these habits and activities, they will help build a foundation for being able to identify people who are emotionally unavailable, who may bring you into that space and shut you down.
不仅仅是你的恋爱关系、与朋友或家人的关系，还有你对待自己的方式。一道心墙可能会倒塌，这或许会伴随着痛苦。许多从童年、挫折经历、分手或创伤中积压下来的负面情绪被压抑着，但我认为许多困难的事情都值得去做，而这就是其中之一。所有这些习惯和活动，它们将帮助你建立一个基础，让你能够识别出那些在情感上不可得的人，他们可能会把你拉入那种情境并让你感到受挫。
I think that's probably the worst part about dating people who are emotionally unavailable, is that this behavioral and emotional pattern is in many ways contagious, and it's can rub off on us by leading us to question how we deserve to be treated and eventually becoming jaded around what true, unconditional, vulnerable love should feel like. They actually did a study on this and what they examined was the impact of having an emotionally unavailable partner. So they found that individuals who reported that they were dating or married or in a long-term partnership with someone who displayed lowered emotional capacity, themselves had a lower emotional capacity. So essentially what that meant was this behavioural pattern, this emotional reaction, this failure to be vulnerable
我想这大概是与情感不可得的人约会最糟糕的部分，那就是这种行为和情感模式在很大程度上具有传染性，它会潜移默化地影响我们，让我们开始质疑自己应该受到怎样的对待，并最终对真实、无条件、充满脆弱感的爱应该是什么感觉变得冷漠。他们实际上对此做过一项研究，他们所检验的是拥有一个情感不可得的伴侣所带来的影响。因此他们发现，那些报告说自己正在与某个表现出较低情感容量的人约会、结婚或维持长期伴侣关系的人，他们自己也拥有较低的情感容量。所以从本质上讲，这意味着这种行为模式、这种情感反应、这种无法展露脆弱
and emotionally intimate, rubs off on those around us. So it's a big reason why you want to avoid these individuals. Take a good, hard look at your beliefs around what you want in a romantic partner. I have suggested this before, but I think it's a godsend. I think it is so valuable if you have found yourself in this cycle of dating and finding people who just always shut you down, who never want to be committed. You need to make a list of non-negotiables and these need to be specific. What are the things that you are not going to tolerate? Especially if you're someone who is looking for a committed relationship. You need to have a half-negotiation. You need to have a half-negotiation. You need to have a line at what you're willing to accept around non-committal dating and romantic experiences.
和情感亲密的行为，会传染给我们周围的人。这就是为什么你要刻意避开这些人的一个重要原因。好好审视一下你对于浪漫伴侣的期望。我以前曾建议过，但我认为这简直是神来之笔。如果你发现自己陷入了这种不断约会却总是遇到那些总是拒绝你、从不想承诺的人的循环中，我认为这个方法真的太有价值了。你需要列出一份不容妥协的底线清单，而且这些底线需要具体。有哪些事情是你绝不容忍的？特别是如果你正在寻找一段承诺关系的。你需要设定一个明确的界限。你需要设定一个明确的界限。对于在非承诺性的约会和浪漫体验中你愿意接受到什么程度，你需要划定一条线。
And a big red flag is someone who is not able to engage in deep emotional conversations or acknowledge your feelings or their own. That's a huge indicator that they're not an emotionally available person. And that doesn't mean that you need to trauma dump on the first date to kind of understand if they're going to reciprocate your emotional intimacy. that's a bit extreme. But I think it's pretty telling as you get further into a relationship, whether they're willing to discuss how they're feeling or how you're feeling,
而一个巨大的危险信号就是，对方无法进行深度的情感对话，也无法承认你或他们自己的感受。这是一个强烈的信号，表明他们是一个情感不可得的人。这并不意味着你需要在第一次约会时就倾倒情感创伤，以此来试探对方是否会回应你的情感亲密，那未免有点极端了。但我认为，随着关系的深入，他们是否愿意讨论自己的感受或你的感受，这其实是非常说明问题的，
and whether they want to connect with you or shut you down. It's also worth questioning, how do you feel about yourself? Is the reason you always find yourself around emotionally unavailable people because you feel that you don't deserve love and a deep connection? Are you actually just terrified? of rejection or are you suffering from low self-esteem due to past relationships? You know, it's not your fault, I think, that a lot of this kind of does sound like it's your responsibility to avoid these people. It's your fault for attracting these people. That's not
以及他们是想要与你连接还是将你推开。这也值得你去反思：你对自己感觉如何？你总是发现自己身边的都是情感不可得的人，是不是因为你觉得自己不配得到爱和深度的连接？你其实只是极度害怕被拒绝，还是因为过去的恋情导致你自尊心低下？你知道，这并不是你的错，我认为，虽然这听起来好像在说你有责任去避开这些人。吸引这些人是你的错。事实并非如此，
the case, I just to think it's something that tends to happen and we don't always know until it's a bit too late or we find ourselves being ghosted by someone that they are emotionally unavailable. and this just kind of helps you to avoid that pain. Much like the previous suggestion, you need to consciously rethink what you deserve and write that down, almost like affirmations. You know, I deserve to be loved. I deserve for my emotions to be reciprocated.
情况其实是这样的，我只是认为这往往会发生，而且往往直到为时已晚，或者发现自己被某人无故失联（ghosting）时，我们才知道对方在情感上是不可得的。而这只是在某种程度上帮助你避免那种痛苦。就像之前的建议一样，你需要有意识地重新思考你值得拥有什么，并把它写下来，就像自我肯定一样。你知道，我值得被爱。我的情感值得得到回应。
It's all about faking it till you make it, I guess, because if you don't feel like you deserve deep, meaningful love and closeness, I promise that you do, and if you continue to tell yourself that, one day you will believe it as well. And whatever you do, if you take one thing out of this, do not try and force someone to change. It is not your responsibility to fix them. I think women in particular have been conditioned by society into believing that it is their duty to nurture others and to offer that maternal healing side of a relationship. But here's another hard truth for those of you who are listening
这一切都关乎“假装直到你真正拥有它”，我猜是这样的，因为如果你觉得自己不配得到深厚、有意义的爱和亲密感，我向你保证，你是配得上的，如果你继续这样告诉自己，总有一天你也会相信的。无论你做什么，如果你只能从中听进去一件事，那就是：不要试图强迫任何人改变。拯救他们不是你的责任。我认为女性尤其被社会潜移默化地灌输了一种观念，认为关爱他人、在关系中提供那种母亲般的治愈是她们的天职。但对于那些正在收听节目的朋友们，这里还有一个残酷的真相：
who may be in denial about an emotionally unavailable person in your life. The more you push, the more you try to artificially create situations that they are forced to be vulnerable in, the more they are going to pull back and they may take you with them. When I was researching this episode, it was shocking how many articles I found with titles like how to get an emotionally unavailable man to chase you how to change an emotionally unavailable man
她们可能对生活中某个情感不可得的人抱有否认心理。你越是推搡，越是试图刻意制造让他们不得不展露脆弱的情境，他们就会退缩得越厉害，甚至可能会把你一同拖入深渊。当我研究这一期节目时，我震惊地发现有那么多文章，标题竟然是“如何让一个情感不可得的男人来追你”、“如何改变一个情感不可得的男人”，
how to use sex to fix emotional unavailability and it was super frustrating to me because I was like we shouldn't be pushing this narrative to either men or women that it is your duty to heal this person so that you can feel safe and vulnerable that is not your job, that is not your responsibility. There are so many other people out there who will have done the work and who will treat you the way you deserve to be treated.
“如何用性来修复情感不可得”，这让我感到超级沮丧，因为我想：我们不应该向男人或女人灌输这样一种观点，即治愈这个人是你的天职，这样你才能感到安全和脆弱——这不是你的工作，这不是你的责任。外面有那么多其他人，他们已经做好了自我成长，会用你应得的方式对待你。
And if you get one thing from this episode, like I said, you cannot change this person. Your job is just to heal yourself and focus on your own emotions and feelings. One final thing I do want to state, it's a bit of a disclaimer, and that's that you don't need to be emotionally available to everyone. That's a critical part of this conversation. I think when we strive for emotional availability, when we enlist all of those tools, sometimes we accidentally find ourselves transforming into someone who is passive when it comes to our relationships, because we force ourselves to hold space for everyone, but sometimes that can be equally as draining as being emotionally unavailable. There is a lot of emotional energy and commitment that goes into sustaining
如果你能从这期节目中收获哪怕一点，就像我说的，你无法改变这个人。你的工作只是治愈自己，专注于你自己的情绪和感受。最后，我还要声明一点，这有点像是一个免责声明，那就是你不需要对所有人都做到情感上可得。这是这场对话中至关重要的一部分。我认为，当我们努力追求情感上的可得性，当我们调动所有这些工具时，有时我们会不小心让自己在对待感情时变得被动，因为我们强迫自己为每个人留出空间，但有时这可能会和情感不可得一样消耗精力。维系深度的连接需要投入大量的
deep connections. And as much as we like to think that that source is infinite, it's not. You have to sometimes accept the fact that you can't give everything to everyone. So be selective. You can still be emotionally available even if you're picky. If anything, it's actually a sign of your availability. because you understand what it means to invest and commit to a friend or a partner or a family member in a way that is meaningful. And that means not exhausting yourself with gathering and collecting every single connection that comes your way. It's how you show up in those relationships with the people you have chosen to invest in and that you care about and who can reciprocate all that love for you that is an indicator and the biggest sign that you are a moment. emotionally available. Thank you so much for listening to this episode. I really hope you learned something.
情感精力和承诺。尽管我们很愿意认为这种资源是无限的，但其实并非如此。你有时必须接受这样一个事实：你无法把所有东西都给每一个人。所以要有选择性。即使你很挑剔，你依然可以做到情感上可得。如果非要说的话，这实际上是你具备情感可得性的一个标志，因为你懂得如何以一种有意义的方式去为一个朋友、伴侣或家人进行投资和承诺。这意味着不要把自己搞得精疲力竭去收集和迎合你遇到的每一个关系。你在那些你选择投入的、你所关心的、并且能够回报你所有爱的人的关系中如何表现，才是你是否真正具备情感可得性的指标和最大标志。非常感谢收听本期节目。我真心希望你有所收获。
I hope you enjoyed it. I definitely did. One of the best parts about doing this podcast is that I get to learn things that are really relevant to me. And this was definitely one of those cases. I had no idea how complicated emotional unavailability was. I think we really do throw that phrase around and say, oh, you know, emotionally unavailable, she's emotionally unavailable without thinking deeply about what that really means. So I hope that this did enlighten you. Maybe there is someone in your life who needs to hear this episode. You should share it with them. You should send them a link. I'm sure they'll thank you later. And as always, if you feel compelled to do so, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you're listening right now.
希望你喜欢它。我绝对很享受。做这个播客最好的部分之一，就是我能学到对自身真正有用的东西。而这次绝对就是其中之一。我以前完全不知道情感不可得竟然这么复杂。我想我们确实经常随口说出这个词，说，“哦，你知道的，情感不可得，她在情感上不可得”，却没有深入思考这究竟意味着什么。所以我希望这确实能启发到你。也许你生命中有谁需要听听这期节目。你应该把它分享给他们。你应该发个链接给他们。我相信他们以后会感谢你的。和往常一样，如果你有这种冲动，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。
It really does help the show to grow and to reach new people. I am so grateful if you have listened this far. Thank you for coming on this journey with me. If you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to be in touch, if you want to see what's going on behind the scenes, please feel free to follow us at that psychology podcast on Instagram. We share a lot of polls around what episodes you want to hear next. That's where this idea came from.
这确实对节目的成长和触达新听众大有帮助。如果你一直听到了这里，我真的非常感激。谢谢你和我一起踏上这段旅程。如果你有节目建议，或者只是想保持联系，想看看幕后发生了什么，请随时在Instagram上关注我们@that psychology podcast。我们会在那里就你接下来想听什么话题发起很多投票。这个创意就是这么来的。
So thank you for all of your suggestions. Hopefully we can see you over there. Or maybe not. It's up to you. I just really hope that you enjoyed this episode. And we will be back next week for another. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
所以感谢你们所有的建议。希望我们能在那里见到你们。或者不见也行。随你便。我只是真心希望你喜欢这期节目。我们下周将回归另一期节目。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast. 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在节目中，我将剖析在我们这个奇异的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。可在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
从1979年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并尝试弄清楚我们是如何在朋友、同僚喜剧作家和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's,
那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，
experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy, to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身穿西装，犹如身披铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你具备这种能力，你就必须这样做。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕，被证实是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天呐，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。